welcome back a huge turnout today for
the annual
walk with the heart of a child event its
goal is to raise funds to support
children who are born with congenital
heart disease
eight news now reporter victoria saha
was there she has our story
the 18th annual walk with the heart of a
child event
is meant to honor those we've lost too
young and for those who are still
fighting congenital heart disease
today's event brought out hundreds of
people
making up for last year's event that was
canceled
the one mile walk may have seemed short
but the turnout goes a long way
for the children's heart foundation more
than 67 teams signed up to walk in this
year's event
with 8 news now meteorologist sheri
swank the emcee
families and kids participated to raise
funds to support the children who were
born with heart defects
studies show one in 100 children are
born with
congenital heart disease each year in
the united states
and many don't survive the first time
right after birth
i was able to take her home for a good
two months and then we went back for her
second surgery
she lasted another month and a half in
the hospital and then i just wasn't able
to bring her home with me
garcia's daughter died at six months
with seven different heart defects
garcia participates in the walk in honor
of her daughter elea
many of the families i spoke with today
say they each have their own battle with
this disease
but participating in this walk makes
them feel like they're not alone
in this fight reporting from craig ranch
regional park victoria zaha